salut on est en plein dans les énigmes
de l'été tous les jours je vous donne
une énigme et le lendemain je vous donne
une nouvelle énigme avec la solution de
l'énigme de la veille et je vais
commencer par vous donner la solution de
l'énigme d'hier donc si vous ne l'avez
pas vu aller vite la voir parce que là
je donne la solution
la réponse à la question d'hier était un
cercueil l'objet dont je parlais était
un cercueil
celui qui me fabrique 9 ans celui qui
m'achètent ne se sert pas de moi on sert
pas l'intérêt y met celui par contre
qu'il se sert de moi ne le sait pas
forcément on sait pourquoi
après si c'est un vampire forcément ça
marche pas pour l'énigme mais on
considère que bon c'est pas un vampire
roissy n'était pas l'énigme la plus
joyeuse mais je la trouvais intéressante
quand même rassurez-vous l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus joyeuse
trouver la suite logique à ses lettres
une des terres qu c allez je vous en
rajoute une en bonus
est-ce pour info c'est pas vraiment un
indice mais cette suite là est infini
jeu pourrait continuer indéfiniment
il ya une logique entre chaque lettre à
vous de les trouver quelle sera la
prochaine m après le s n'hésitez pas à
en parler dans les commentaires mais ne
donnait pas la réponse si vous avez la
bonne réponse mais tu es un pouce en
l'air comme ça on sera le nombre de
personnes qui a trouvé la réponse
hulu alors dans les commentaires vous
mettre moi je sais et vous mettez votre
pouce l'intérêt étant de laisser les
autres chercher jusqu'à demain puisque
la réponse vous la donne demain dans le
prochain mentale vlog à 17h avec la
nouvelle énigme profitez bien du soleil
et rendez vous demain ciao
oui